Shannon I believe you said in an
interview that you had a professor say
to you one time how is it you can help
all the other writers figure out their
problems but you can't do it for
yourself
something like that that's exactly what
he said and of course in that moment it
was soul-crushing right you take it as a
criticism but actually what it made me
realize is the writers room part the
workshopping part was the part that I
enjoyed the most so it actually made me
take a step back and say hey this is the
part that I think is fun
I love reading other people's stuff and
finding those problems it's like a
puzzle to me I actually have had someone
ask me before like why do you enjoy this
so much and it's like somebody who's
trying to crack a math problem or
someone who's trying to put a puzzle
together I love being able to read
screenplays and figure out what the
holes are and how to fix them and
actually by working on other people's
stuff so often it actually helps me with
my stuff as well so it all came back
full circle so you were doing your
undergraduate or I was in getting my MFA
yes MFA yes at Florida State University
and so like how far in were you when
this professor said this oh good
question I think I think I was in my
last well at Florida State we do a
two-year program but it's two years
straight so that fall spring summer fall
spring summer so we don't graduate until
August so this could have been in the
spring or it might have been in the
summer but of my last year because we
had a program that was in the film
school the theatre program and the
creative writing program so we got to do
television scripts screenplay feature
screenplays plays and short stories so
we got to do all of it so we spent time
in all of those different programs and
all those different buildings so if I
can remember correctly I believe we
didn't do our features until the last
part of our program so this was like
after I had basically spent almost two
years being in that workshop kind of
field and always being that person who
like can see like okay I see where this
problem is or have you thought of
so you know what's going on here so I
guess by then he had kind of picked up
on like you do that really really well
even though that's not be fit it sounded
like he was giving a criticism but
that's what I took from it and that's
one of the reasons I decided to go into
development when I got out to LA instead
of taking the traditional writers route
of becoming a writers assistant or
writers PA and trying to get into a
writing room have you always been like
that because you said you were the
youngest in your family yes I haven't
always been this okay it's so funny
somebody asked one of my friends like
what was Shannon like in high school and
they said just like this but with penny
loafers and it's weird because I have on
some loafers today but it's like yeah
I've always been that kind of a mediator
kind of person people come to me for
advice and stuff and I've just always
been that way no matter how a young guy
was and people would always tell me
you're wise beyond your years and then I
found out that my name's Shannon
actually means little old wise one oh
wow yeah so it's like okay well then you
know I guess nature versus nurture kind
of thing this is just who I am you know
very interesting so when this professor
said that how long did you get depressed
and throw a pity party or maybe you
didn't and then realize wait a minute
this might actually be a gift I think it
was almost immediate like maybe right
after class like I I don't think I had
this moment in the middle of class when
he said it cuz he sat in front of
everybody this was like the way in our
program there were six writers so
they're only six of us so it's not a
room you know filled with people and
begin by then we had been together for
two and a half years so we've already
heard the criticism of everybody's work
so it's an open space it's free space so
I didn't feel any kind of way because he
said it in front of them but you know of
course because all my life I wanted to
be a writer all my life this is
something that I wanted to do and all my
life I've been told that I'm good at it
and so to hear in this moment not that
you're not good at it but you're really
good at helping other people more than
you are at helping yourself because when
you're with your own story
your internal with it you know what I
mean there are things that you're going
to be missing and you need those other
sets of eyes and ears which is why we do
workshops in the first place that's why
Writers Workshop they're stuff so I
don't you know definitely didn't mind
being told like oh well you have
problems you know in your writing of
course I do every
so it didn't take me long I didn't you
know wallow in it very long I don't know
how I even got to the development place
because at that age I still didn't know
what development meant and it's weird
because you go to film school but they
teach you all the creative part and you
don't really learn the business part you
don't really learn about how the
business side of the industry works
you're just learning all of your above
the line and at Florida State greatly we
also learned the below-the-line
positions so we I could do everything
that's in your career in the credits at
the end of a script I've done every
single one of those things so that it
was a great program but somehow someway
I stumbled into development I don't know
what I was googling this was you know in
2008 I was you know so I don't know what
I was googling but somehow someway I got
to development and I was like oh that
that is what I'm good at that is
something that I want to get into
what makes you great at story oh great
that's a good question what makes me
great at story okay so I think what
makes me great at story is that I
understand story and there's a
difference between having an idea and
having a story and I think a lot of
people get stuck in the idea phase which
basically means you have an element to a
story like you might have a great
character you might have a great
situation for you to put for you to put
them in there might be a great world
that has that you've started to
originate but until you have every
single one of those elements you don't
yet have a story so me understanding
what it takes to have a story helps me
to help writers get to the place where
they have a full story and so I'm able
to look at what they have and say okay
so you've got a great idea but now how
do we make that into a story how do we
make how do we give this character some
depth and then give them an actual goal
so that they can have something to do
during their story or how do we have
this goal and give a character who would
be great at actually making the goal
happen or the total opposite they could
never make that goal happen so now their
journey is gonna be getting to a place
of actually being able to reach that
goal so I'm always looking into it to
see what elements do you have what
elements do you need and how can we
really flesh out what your full story is
and is that because sometimes they're
actually writing a story that's loosely
based on them or no it is sometimes
sometimes I I have dealt with a lot of
writers who are writing something that
is based on truth and it's really easy
to get stuck in that and that's because
when you're stuck in truth you're stuck
in trying to tell the truth and I always
say to them go look at the actual films
that are based on true stories and read
that line underneath based on a true
story right which means that you can't
get hung up in what actually happened
because in most of our lives everyday is
not entertaining even if you look at
reality television right they have their
cameras there for 12 hours a day and
they're filming but you at home are not
watching 12 hours of them filming
someone because there's not enough
there's not enough entertaining stuff
happening so the producers are going to
take all of that footage and
go home and craft a story which is why
you may then have people dressed in one
way having a conversation in the next
five minutes they're in another place
having that same conversation but we
don't know those conversations could
have been months apart but they built
the story for us because we have to
understand what it is that we're
following so the same thing is true when
it's in scripted form just because it's
based on true story doesn't mean it's
dramatic enough doesn't mean it's
entertaining enough so we have to figure
out what's the story that you're
actually trying to tell like what's the
root thing and then let's put all the
elements to it regardless to whether
it's the truth and then let's tell the
story but I think in general writing is
one of those things that a lot of people
don't understand has a skill to it has a
structure to it so people wake up and
say I want to be a writer
because I have this great idea and I
give the example of if I were a 35 year
old man who had never played football a
day in my life never and then I woke up
one day and said I'm gonna go walk into
an NFL team people would look at me like
I was insane so I give that same look
when people just wake up and say I'm a
writer because I have an idea it's like
you still got to go build that muscle
you still gotta go go to practice write
by writing and writing and writing
before you can get to a place where you
can assume that you're gonna have like
Shonda Rhimes kind of script right just
like I'm not gonna wake up one day and
just be able to be in the NFL so I think
people kind of get stuck in that place
because it's creative and so they think
well there are no rules anybody can be
creative yes anybody can be creative but
that doesn't necessarily mean that you
have all the elements that you need for
a story and it's a great point and you
know you talked about you know based on
a true story or whatever based on it's
funny that you mentioned that because
there's at least two films right now
great films but when I went back and
read and did some research on the
stories that they were based on some
very major parts were left out mm-hmm
and I was talking to David about him
like why would they leave this out I
think you were saying that it's because
maybe just didn't finish the story
didn't fit into the story right and the
story has to be king
the writer cannot be pushing a narrative
even though sometimes you will watch
things and obviously the writers saying
this is what I'm trying to say right but
some of the best are
is giving you all of the information and
let letting you decide what they're
trying to say or are you getting lost in
well is it this or is it that and you
having to come up with your own decision
about it first is the writer just
sending you to it so I often tell people
the characters have to be making
decisions based on who they are not
based on who you are right so you may
need for your character to get from A to
B and so you're saying well I'm gonna
have them do it this way but would that
character do it that way
or are you just forcing them into doing
something because you need to get them
to the other end so I'm hoping that
that's the reason that they didn't put
it in there just didn't work into the
you know to the arc of the story and so
if it was gonna push the story in a
different direction or show you a
different side of the person that you
didn't want them to see you know what I
mean because if you establish a
character as being one way and then they
act in a way that's not within those
bounds you now have raised a question
for your audience so now your audience
is going to be thinking for the rest of
the film well what was that well what
does that mean and how does that
influence blah-blah-blah-blah-blah and
if it literally doesn't influence
anything else and the character just
absent mindedly acted without on the
outside of themselves that question
never leaves and now we might leave the
theater going it was just something
about it you know like we can't maybe we
can't put our finger on it some people
might be able to say well it's because
they did this and that's why it doesn't
make any sense to me most people won't
really be able to put their finger on it
but they'll be thinking to themselves
there's something there that I just
didn't understand and it's because that
character made a decision outside of
what you told us he or she was so
sometimes it's best to leave those
things out unless you are purposefully
showing me that so I gave an example to
I'm teaching an online class right now
and I gave an example to a student and
it said if there's a woman who is
ex-military and she is fighting men like
physically fighting right and she fights
one she fights two she fights three she
fights for but when five comes she
freaks she freezes and she runs then
that tells me there's something there
some things going on with this
particular guy she just fought four
other guys why didn't she fight him now
if it never comes back so I understand
why she didn't fight him
gonna have that question for the rest of
the time I'm gonna wonder what that was
and so that might have been the first
breadcrumb to teach us something between
them something from her past something
about something about him made her
freeze and flee instead of fight so
everything within the film has to be
working towards you know that story and
if it's not then just leave it up and
that and you're right that was it was
two different films and that and that
was it it did it made the character look
different
great point okay excellent everyone can
write but is everyone a writer great
question everyone can write and everyone
can be a writer but I think the bigger
question is what part of the creative
process are you trying to be a part of
and a lot of people don't know that
there are so many other ways of being a
part of the creative process in this
particular industry that you don't have
to be a writer so I think because of the
lack of knowledge people know there's a
director they know there's a writer they
know there's a producer some people
might not think past those three things
right and so they're thinking to
themselves a lot of people think well I
want to be the writer because the writer
is the person who's in charge you know
they're the ones who are making the
story they're the ones who get to say
what happens little do they know that
the writer is not in charge the writer
puts that stuff on the script
they may receive their paycheck and they
may not be a part of the rest of the
process because there are other people
who have creative jobs throughout the
process so I definitely think anybody
can be a writer but I do think that they
have to want to hone the skill and they
have to respect the art but in but other
than that some people and this is what I
enjoyed about going to Florida State's
film school because we did get to learn
all of the below-the-line positions some
people get in and realize I don't want
to be the director I want to be the
camera operator everyone thinks that the
camera operators the director right like
if you know people who are at home who
might just within a movie see a movie
being made they assume that the person
who's actually behind the camera is the
director and it's like no the directors
over there in the chair watching the
monitor you know so they can see the
whole frame etc and some people really
want to be the person physically out
there with the camera so I think if we
just had more knowledge about all of the
parts of the process and how you can be
a part of that process many people
wouldn't
use writing because even if we just
think about it in general a lot of
people just aren't aren't that great
with the English language period a lot
of people don't like to write period you
know some people don't like to read
that's just not their thing that's
totally fine but to then have this
creative thing that you want to get out
it's like yeah well you can be a non
writing producer you can be the person
who has the ideas and then hire someone
who can actually do the physical writing
because they've you know been able to
master that skill in some kind of way
but I think it just really comes from a
place of having ideas and not knowing
how they can fit into the overall puzzle
of the industry and have a creative
voice so then going back to that
hypothetical person that wakes up one
day and says I want to be a writer and a
really cool story everyone's gonna love
this they need to know that that's not
exactly how it works and it takes a lot
of time and what do you say to that one
that you said the person at home
watching TV and maybe they did have an
incredible life and they overcame a lot
of challenges but they're not really
writers yeah I think it's hard to make
people understand that they're not
writers right I think just like with the
example of thinking of an athlete people
think they know what athletes look like
people think they know what the skill
sets should be if you're an athlete some
people have athletic bodies you might
not know what kind of sport they play
right but they walk into the room and
you're thinking oh you're probably some
kind of athlete with writers there's no
additional thing like that because
anybody can be a writer so I say if you
have an idea respect the craft enough to
then go hone your skill that doesn't
mean you have to go to film school film
school is not for everyone
I enjoy film school because I like
learning in a classroom structure right
but I could have had that same education
by just going and being on some sets I
think all writers should PA at some time
all writers should be on set so that you
can see what it takes to get done what
you're asking people to do right so you
can understand what budgets actually
look like when you're writing your car
chasing and you know writing your action
scenes and understanding that needing
blood and eating prosthetics and needing
stunt doubles and eating all these
people all of that is gonna cost money
right so just hone your skill hone your
craft there are online courses I teach
online courses I
give feedback on on screenplays because
I'm not saying don't try you definitely
should try but within that process get
some feedback and get better one of the
things that I tell people is if this is
actually your baby if you think this
this is the best idea idea ever don't
practice on your baby practice on some
other ideas so that you can get good and
then write your baby because you want
people to take your baby seriously the
other thing is I tell people stop
calling it your baby it's not your baby
at some point you're gonna have to sell
your baby and you don't want to write so
realize that it's art and it's there for
other people to participate in the
process and on your side of it if you're
trying to be a professional writer
because not everybody is trying to be a
professional writer some people just
have an idea and that's the thing they
want to get made some people actually
want to have writing as their profession
meaning this is how they make money this
is how they feed their families and
those people are the ones that really
have to let go of the baby because you
just need to be writing things so that
you can be making income right so your
baby somebody else's baby whoever's baby
you'll write whatever you need to write
so that you can have a consistent income
but for those people who just have an
idea and that's the thing that they want
to get made do the work make sure that
it's good stuff find some other people
to come in and be a part of the process
I tell writers all the time if you're
not a director and you don't want to be
a director go find someone to direct
your to direct your script because if
you're gonna take the time to put in the
money and the energy of actually making
the film then you want that product to
look good so what if you write a good
screenplay but you don't get the people
necessary so that you can make it look
good on the screen and then now the
thing that you have to represent your
screenplay is not representing it very
well right the same thing is true if
you're a director but you're not a
writer and you don't want to learn how
to be a writer go find one of your
writer friends who has a script and then
you can direct that there so this is a
collaborative process it's collaborative
effort and as writers we a lot of times
get stuck with thinking it's just me and
my computer right it's like well no
there's so many other people who
participate in this process so anybody
who has an idea can write it whether it
will be good whether it will fit the
structure whether it's something that is
a part of the art you know because I get
stuck in that place of like just respect
the art you know go out there and get
the information that you need so that
you can have something that's great on
the page and when you hear certain code
words or you see a demeanor in someone
how do you know that ooh this one these
people where we're gonna have to have a
talk because they're too precious with
their material let's see I think I think
the code words are as simple as they're
always talking about my and well when I
get there they'll know and I'll tell
them in blah blah blah and I always have
to say to them you might not be there
like you just physically might not be
there just understanding the political
space in the process like I even have a
Hollywood pyramid that I show people
that I made and I show them who is king
the studios are king the networks are
the team of the King production
companies are not far under them then
you have all of the executives you have
all of the above the line people and the
writer is way down at the bottom because
they are just the first part of the
process and after they're part of the
process is over everybody else has to do
theirs right it's one of the reasons
that no one invites the writers not no
one but people don't often invite the
writers to the set because they don't
want to hear the writers going well this
is what it was supposed to be in blah
blah blah and now they're giving notes
and it's like that part of the process
is the directors part of the process he
or she is now bringing his or her vision
to your script so you don't know what
direction it's going in now and now
you're invited to set and you're on set
giving notes to actor who's in talking
to all of these people and you're now
out of line you've now stepped outside
of your bounds so it's really easy to
see when people don't know that that's
how the process goes so I always just
say hey I just want to give you what the
what the help you set your expectation
of what this will be and it doesn't mean
that there aren't exceptions there are
exceptions there are people who write
their films and they're also able to be
producers and be there along the way so
it's possible does it
happen often for someone who's writing
their very first film not at all you
know and that's just a part of the part
of the business and so a lot of people
don't have the knowledge of the business
and that's one of the reasons why I
exist as a script consultant so that you
can call me and ask me and I can just
tell you what it is and again anytime I
give people advice I always tell them
somebody did it another way like this is
not the kind of industry that has a
step-by-step this is how you make it
kind of thing not for actors not for
writers not for anybody everybody gets
there in a different way so it's totally
possible that you can get that get there
the way that you want to get there but
generally speaking this is how things
work in the industry is it true that
beginning writers need the most help
with structure no oh you know I think
all writers need help with structure
okay I think there are writers right now
who are employed and writers rooms who
have soules features before and they
need help with structure I definitely do
and the way that you know that that's
true is because there are Ari writers
who have jobs a lot of the times when
someone sells a feature just because
they sold it doesn't mean that's the way
it's gonna make it onto the screen right
so they may buy it because they like the
idea they may buy it because they like
the characters they may buy it because
they like the world they may buy it
because they like you you never know
things happen but before that thing goes
to the next round they're gonna hire
someone else to come in and tighten it
up to come in and restructure to come in
and give it what it needs and this is
something that I do as well I work with
a lot of writers who have something
great on the page but structurally
speaking it's not hitting the beats that
it needs to hit like when you if your
script gets on someone's desk finally
makes it in they're gonna have their
intern or their assistant read it first
somebody who may or may not have ever
written a thing in their lives somebody
who may or may not have a degree someone
who may have just gotten their day one
and they're gonna be the people who read
your script they're gonna have to read
the entire thing because that's their
job and then they're gonna write
coverage on it which means they're gonna
say this is good this is bad this is
ugly these are what the characters are
executive you should or you should not
read it that's basically what the
coverage is going to do the executive
will then say okay they're gonna take it
and because they have eight million
scripts on their desk they're gonna give
it about 10 to 15 pages to hit
particular beats before they decide to
continue to read there's kind of like a
industry standard of you got to give it
at least a tenner for the first ten or
15 pages some people including myself
can give it three pages and know this
isn't gonna it's not gonna do what it's
supposed to do but because I'm a script
consultant I almost have to read you
know everything so I usually can't just
give it a few pages I have to read
everything so that I can give detailed
notes about what's going on but as far
as an executive goes they know what
they're looking for
first of all wherever it is they're
working has a brand so if they're at Fox
they're not gonna buy what CBS would buy
they're not gonna buy what NBC would buy
they're not gonna buy what own would buy
they each have their own brand their own
audiences and things that they're
looking for so outside of looking for
those story beasts are also looking for
but would we put this on our channel
because regardless to how great it is if
it's not something that would be on
their channel they're not going to
continue to read it it's a waste of
their time to continue to read it so
with that being said structure matters
as far as Hollywood goes if you're an
independent writer an independent
producer independent director you can
write what you want to write and make
what you want to make because it's your
money
but as far as Hollywood goes there are
particular things that they're looking
for we haven't hit that inciting
incident around page 15 they're not
gonna keep reading when I used to teach
at Florida State I taught a intro to
film and the whole class was we would
watch films and then they would have to
analyze them in the written form and I
would always say if I get your essay and
I haven't hit the thesis statement I
would even give them the whole page even
though we all know thesis statement
should be in the first paragraph but if
I get to the bottom of page one and I
haven't gotten to the thesis statement
I'm not continuing to read because
you're making me guess what your paper
is about I shouldn't have to guess what
it's about you should tell me this is
what this thing is
about or this is what I'm going to try
to prove to you or whatever that's what
the inciting incident is for the
screenplay for you to give me the
information of this is what this thing
is about this is what my character is
going to be doing for all of Act two or
this is what goal my character is trying
to reach in the resolution if I can't
know that by page 15 I'm not gonna keep
looking for it you know and so that's
why structure matters and there are some
people who don't who write who naturally
write well and don't know that they're
writing in that structure and then there
are some people who have great ideas and
great characters and great worlds and
the reason that the things aren't
selling or aren't doing what they need
to do is because they don't have any
structure so I think everybody can learn
from structure every single person some
people the people who have mastered it
are those people who are consistently
making money as writers because if you
understand structure you can write
anybody story not just your own and a
lot of us think that being a writer is
all about writing our own ideas and
there are some people who get to that
level that their writing their own ideas
but most professional writers people who
are consistently getting paid are people
who are being hired by producers to
write for them or hire to do rewrites on
somebody else's stuff or someone who can
jump from writers room to writers room
to writers room and continue to go up in
in rank in those writers rooms because
they can hear someone else's story and
because they know structure they can
make it happen so structure is just
gonna be helpful all the way around is
there one structure upon which almost
every story will fit into there are
several different types of structures
and it depends on what kind of story
you're telling
so we have three act structure and
that's the one that almost everybody
knows and in my opinion three act
structure is the best to know because
even if you're writing in five acts all
it means is that you're stretching out
your 3x right or if you're writing in 2x
you're convincing your 2x or for those
those people who are into theater if
you're writing a one-act play your three
acts is happening in one act so
understanding 3x structure which
basically means you pick you spend one
act on setting up you spend one act on
actually getting to the to the goal and
you spend another act on saying hey I
got the goal now what
and that's basically what the struck
what structure is so a lot of people
will write pages and pages and pages of
activity but activity is not action
right action is intentional right people
are taking intentional steps towards a
goal activity is just anything I went to
a party I sat in my house I watch TV I
did XY and Z but if that isn't attached
to you actually trying to reach a goal
then what am i watching I'm watching the
12 hours of a reality TV show when
someone just sat there all day and
filmed let's say they were filming us
right now what would they be seeing just
you sitting here right but what does
that mean however if they were filming
about how what it takes for you to make
your show happen now this becomes an
intentional part of the story but if the
story is about you going to the grocery
store today then why would we need to be
showing this right so yes there is one
particular structure that if everybody
learns it's gonna be helpful to you but
most features are written in 3x someone
our dramas urban in three acts some are
written in five and in comedies
half-hour comedies those can be written
in 2x or also 3x depending upon what
kind of comedies they are single-camera
comedies are usually done in 3x
multi-camera comedies might be done in
two so what I say to people is going
back to that homework going back to
honing your craft is read scripts that
are close to the script that you're
writing so that you can see what kind of
structure and what kind of format they
use because even the format can change
from features to TV from one hour to
half-hour so in order to know that and
those are those things where it's like
well I'm gonna walk in on my date on my
first day and be showrunner it's like
yes but you don't know that there's a
different format between half-hour
multi-camera comedy and a single-camera
comedy that's information that you
should probably know if you're gonna run
the show right and the information is
out there because now we live in 2020
and there's YouTube there's Instagram
and there are people who are giving the
information away for free so when people
don't take the opportunity to use
utilize those resources then
when I go back to you got to respect the
craft does the protagonist always need a
character arc in my opinion yes but it
doesn't have to be a big one right so
for example this is TV so it's a little
bit different in TV the the art can be
like this big right it doesn't really
have to go anywhere if we think about
house the biggest thing for him is that
he's like a criminal
you know curmudgeon kind of guy like
he's grumpy I don't need to see him
become joyful by the end of the series
right but there may be something else in
him that is gonna change tiny bit by
tiny bit by tiny bit as the series goes
whereas if you look at a show like
scandal Olivia Pope starts with the
white hat by the end of the series she's
got a black hat right but that we get
all of that time to see her grow so what
I say to people is most of the time your
protagonist is moving not because they
just have an external goal but because
the internal goal is what really needs
to be fixed and as they're going along
their journey and hitting complications
that thing is going to be fixing the
inside so even if they never reach the
outside they still have a great
conclusion and that doesn't have to
always be you know 180 degree kind of
turn again I don't want if I like you
because you're grumpy like oh here's a
great example up right if you think of
the Disney movie the the Pixar movie up
he begins as a grumpy man he ends as a
grumpy man but he's now a grumpy man
with a friend right he's now allowed
himself to be open for love the journey
was I need to get this house to whatever
falls and whatever Falls it is I can't
remember right you need to get the house
to the Falls because that's where I need
to be so that I can feel good enough
because I told my wife I would do this
and I didn't while she was alive that's
what it's about him feeling like guilty
and bad because he didn't do what he
promised his wife that's why he won't
talk to anybody that's why he's grumpy
that's why he won't sell his house
that's why he won't do any of those
things and then here comes this kid who
is a complication for him but because
he's now responsible for the kid he has
to eventually choose between house and
kids
so does that mean if I don't get my
house to where I said I was gonna get it
to that I didn't keep my promise to my
wife or would my wife also be ok with me
saving the child from dying right so by
the end of it we now see the same grumpy
man he's got the same look on his face
but he shows up to this kids pinning and
now we know he's changed that's it it
can be something just that subtle it
doesn't have to be a whole 180 degree
kind of kind of turn but also if you're
thinking about the inside it's easier to
show how that inside of you may change
that it is that outside
do you believe that writers should stay
with one genre I'll tell you this I
always tell my writers to pick a lane
and it's not because it's what I believe
but it's because of what Hollywood
believes Hollywood likes to put people
in boxes right it's the same thing with
actors right if you get in as a comedian
it's gonna be hard-pressed for them to
give you a dramatic role it doesn't mean
you can't do it it's just that the
industry in itself when it comes to
writers is really divided into separate
places like there are feature agents and
feature execs there are TV agents and TV
execs they are going to be show runners
who deal with drama show runners who
deal with comedy they usually don't
reach into each other's lanes and
because of that when they meet you as a
new writer they need to know what Lane
you're in so they can know where to send
you that's like one of them just most
foundational things the other thing is
imagine someone coming to your door and
trying to sell you a product and while
they're trying to sell you that product
they're also talking about the other
products that they have now you've got
all these choices to make and you're
thinking okay I'm overwhelmed this is a
lot thank you for your time whereas if
they had just come with their one broom
it showed you everything that the broom
did you still might not want it but at
least you understand what the broom is
about right so it's the same thing when
you come in as a writer if I come in and
I say so I do documentaries I do
features I do comedy and sometimes a
drama do drama and I really like horror
then the people are saying you don't
know what you like and you're probably
not great at any of it simply because
even if you think about just spreading
yourself thin right being good at
everything but a master of nothing and
George opticell that you're a master of
this one thing also because they then
you're never talking to the person who's
giving you the job they always have to
go into another room and sell you and
pitch you they can't do that if they
don't know who you are or what you are
or what Lane you are if they go into the
next room and say yeah she's a comedy
person but she does horror then the
person in the next room is gonna go what
am I supposed to do with that versus if
you come in and you say
I'm the horror person or I'm the greedy
horror person or I'm because sometimes
people do make funny horror things you
know I'm the you know the Corky horror
person or whatever that thing is but
you're selling that is like this is what
I am and my writing samples show this is
what I am because sometimes we'll say
this is what I am and your writing
samples show something else right so
those two things have to match but if
you can come in and say I'm the horror
girl or I do the quirky horror stuff
then again going back to being a
consistent writer is getting all of
those random gigs now somebody in other
room says you know what I just got this
quirky horror scripts and it just
doesn't feel quite right maybe I can
hire her to come take a look at it now
you got a job because they were able to
sell you as that thing if you come in
and you say you're five things you can
end up anywhere like for example you
might like to watch drama but you like
to write comedy but you went into the
room and you said I love drama and I
love comedy and I love this and I love
that so now they're pitching you to
drama show run show runners and they
decide okay yeah let's bring this person
in now you're stuck writing drama for
however long when this is not what you
wanted to be writing at all but that's
what you went into the room talking
about right so I say pick a lane simply
because you have to be able to sell
yourself and people can understand when
you have decided I am a master of this
particular thing with that being said
once you've proven that you're a master
in that thing gonna let you do whatever
you want so it doesn't mean you're not
allowed to write both and it doesn't
mean you can't do both
it just means pick one master it get in
the door and then say hey I also have
this other thing and then now they're
more willing to listen because you've
already proven yourself so if Shonda
Rhimes walks in right now and says I'm
gonna make a feature no one's gonna say
no she's already proven herself that she
knows what she's doing even though she
may have never made a feature before I
don't know maybe she has but we don't
know her as a feature writer right but
she still may walk in and say I want to
do a feature and they'll allow that now
because she's already proven herself so
the same thing is true for any new
writer pick a lane so that you can
master it get him get your foot in the
door prove to them that you know how to
show up you know how to write you
understand structure you can get the
thing done and then pull out whatever
other things you want to pull out of
your
and nine times out of ten because they
now trust you and know you they'll allow
you to move wherever it is you want to
move what if someone says well I don't
want to label myself then I would say
they're in the wrong industry an
industry of labels you have to pick one
and if you don't they'll pick one for
you that's the thing about it right so
you can go into a room and say well I
don't want to label myself I can write
anything they're still gonna put a label
on you because they have to they have to
sell you they have to do their part I
mean and the only way they can do that
is by using descriptors and adjectives
so at some point there's gonna be a
label put on you so if you don't choose
it for yourself they will choose it for
you and then you can still end up going
down a road that you didn't want to go
down because they've decided well I
don't have any other information so I'm
gonna read your your your specs and read
your samples and then I'm going to
assume that this is what you write and
this is what you'd like to do and now
I'm gonna send you down that path and
then you're gonna be wondering oh but I
don't think I put me up for any comedy
things because you gave them three drama
scripts so they just assumed
and then they lit the labels get even
smaller if you send in three drama
scripts and each of them have a teenage
girl as the protagonist they will assume
you write teenage girl drama scripts so
now they're only gonna put you up for
stuff for teenage girls and drama you
know because the point is you're
supposed to be mastering the voice
you're supposed to be mastering an
experience you're supposed to be the the
expert of this experience right and so
if you don't come in with your own label
they're gonna give you one
what makes for a good story hmm I
personally think anything can make for a
good story most people will not agree
with me but because I think structure
matters I think anything can make a good
story also any of us have gone to the
movies and seen something really
terrible you know we're like how did
that get here right so that means
there's an audience for everything I
don't have to like it somebody else is
at home looking at it right now thinking
it's the best thing they've ever seen so
because there are so many you know it's
a it's subjective it's a subjective
thing so when I work with writers I
always told them don't ask me if I liked
it it doesn't matter it just really
doesn't also I'm pretty hard to please
so I almost never like anything and I
don't mean like it means that I dislike
it
it's just I'm one of those people who
like lives on seven you know I'm just
always cool
so I don't ever really get excited about
stuff so it's like I can't read and I go
I was good and they're expecting me
going oh my god it was great but it's
like that's just not my personality so I
would say don't ask me about if I
thought it was good or not because that
part doesn't matter I may not be your
audience I may be your audience and I
still don't like it I see stuff on TV or
in theaters all the time but I don't
like so this is not about what I like
this is about if you are executing the
story to the to your best ability if
you're executing it in a way that
everyone who is gonna like this
particular thing understands the story
you're gonna tell because at the end of
the day you can't stand outside of every
theater in the United States of America
and say hey so on this part this is what
I really meant I think you know hey this
is did you understand that part okay I
figured people wouldn't understand that
so let me explain to you how I go you
can't do that so we got to make sure all
of that's on the page execution is
what's gonna matter more than whether I
like it or not so I think that any idea
can become a story and that story can be
considered good by someone is there a
movie or TV show that gets you to eight
or nine let's see I'm usually pretty
moved by television I like television so
let's see I like Queens sugar
I like the shy I loved brothers and
sisters on ABC I could rewind I'm not a
person likes to rewatch things I will
rewatch the entire series and brother
brothers and sisters Friday Night Lights
is one of the best TV shows ever made
for me also I'm from Texas so it just
you know when the main title sequence
sequence would come on sometimes I would
cry oh wow like it just it moves me and
it's also something about it feels like
Texas so it feels like home like even
like small things that would be
happening in the background it's like
that's so southern that's the kind of
thing you would definitely see traveling
through a town like this you know and so
I appreciate shows that know how to make
the city a character so that's another
reason why I like the shy I'm not from
Chicago so people from Chicago may feel
totally different but when I watch it I
feel like this feels like it's that
whatever that thing is they're trying to
sell me I'm into it and I feel that the
same thing with the wire this feels like
this is Baltimore to me and actually
having living lived on the East Coast
and lived in Washington DC and gone down
to Baltimore a few times I was in some
of those areas and as soon as I got into
those areas I was like yeah like this is
what I saw on television and I could
feel that through the screen some of my
favorite movies I love the quiet place
it's actually something I used to teach
in my classes with because it it screams
show don't tell because they don't act
they actually don't have very much
dialogue which means they have you have
to be able to show me in the screenplay
what you're trying to get these people
to portray instead of telling me so it's
a great a great script to use for that
I like enemy of the state with Will
Smith I think that was in like 1998 that
it came out so there are things that I
definitely like and things that
definitely move me but just like on a
daily basis when I read I read so many
screenplays and I try to explain to
people like it's really hard to have a
unique idea we're all living in the same
world we're all watching the same news
we're all dealing with the same kind of
things if you grew up in the United
States of America everybody went to
elementary school and in middle school
and had some kind of junior prom and
then went to high school and had some
kind of prom we all have been doing
those kind of things so a lot of the
times we're telling the same story
the thing that makes it unique is that
it's your experience right
so that goes back to well is it a good
idea I mean maybe five people have
written it before so what's what are you
gonna be able to bring to it that makes
it stand out and make it not the same
story all over again or make it so that
it's so good that they make it anyway
like if you remember I can't ever
remember the name of both of the movies
one is no strings attached and the other
one I think is something about friends
but one of them start Justin Timberlake
and one start Ashton Kutcher came out in
the exact same year and they were the
exact same movie the exact same movie so
I say to people if 100 people had the
idea maybe 25 we're gonna write it maybe
10 of them are gonna finish it maybe
three people are gonna get in the room
to actually pitch it and this time two
of them got me and at the exact same
time so I always tell people don't don't
be concerned if it's not that unique and
vide it obviously doesn't have to be
it's really just about how you execute
it and what your experience is it's
gonna make it this much unique so you
love the TV show Friday Night Lights
yes did you like the movie I actually
probably saw the movie once I've never
thought about it again okay and then the
blind side and the blind side I enjoyed
that Sandra Bullock was okay awesome but
yeah with Friday Night Lights the movie
I wasn't very moved but the TV show
interesting I don't even know what made
me watch the TV show to be honest with
you maybe because it was in Texas maybe
that was the only reason I was like okay
I'll check it out I have no idea but I
watched it and I was immediately hooked
and I usually have to give a show three
episodes before I am actually into it
this one got me on the pilot pilot
episode I was in and the opening mm-hmm
yeah those main title sequence yeah it's
great
what makes a great storyteller hmm I
think what makes a great storyteller is
someone who is open to the collaborative
process open to knowing that as we're
taught when we're little two heads are
better than one
but for whatever reason we come we
become adults and we want to do
everything by ourselves so I think great
storytellers understand their part of
the process they understand that other
people can bring stuff to the process
they're open to utilizing what's
happening in the world around them so
for example I traveled for a decade as a
touring artist so I was always in
different places so that means I've met
different kinds of people I saw
different kinds of places and we never
really pay attention to the fact that
because I was in that area or around
those people I probably picked up on
some new information so we're always
told to write what we know and that
automatically becomes so narrow to us
when we think about well how I know but
it's like if you consider the places
that you've been the people that you've
met what your spouse may do for a living
what your parents may have done for a
living what your friends may be doing
what they may be going through in their
personal lives if you were a child and
you watched how mom and dad did X Y & Z
all of these things are things that you
know and therefore things that you can
write about so you just have to be open
storytellers have to be open to notes
that's a I think we all know as artists
you have to be open to criticism but
criticism is different from notes and a
lot of the times writers aren't able to
tell the difference they're thinking the
executives are coming in here to steal
my joy okay you know into to rain on my
parade and really they're coming in with
a totally different part of the process
they are coming in from a totally
different spectrum to look at your
script and nine times out of ten if they
have a note all that means is there's a
problem here you can decide to fix it in
any creative way sometimes they will
tell you no this is what it has to be
and that's usually because again they're
coming from a different place they may
know something about the location that
you don't know they may know something
about permits that you don't know they
may know something about the actors that
you don't know they may have information
that again if they're pushing towards
their brand
and whatever it is that you're writing
now seems to be taking them out of that
brand then they're gonna be saying
alright nope let's take this outlet you
know do this or do that but I think as
creatives we will then take that
personally and think that that's
criticism instead of understanding their
doing their part on the team you're
doing your part on the team so don't
take it personally or negatively just
realize that they're coming in it coming
into the situation from a different
perspective so storytellers have to be
open to that too
so as much as we have to respect the art
we also have to understand that there's
a business side of the art and a lot of
the times that means you may have to
compromise your art to the people who
are paying for it which again goes back
to that whole baby thing right like the
point of view writing it is so that
other people can see it the only way
other people are gonna see it unless you
have your own money if someone else buys
it and once they buy it it's now theirs
so they're the ones who get to say when
what direction it goes into and what
schools it's gonna go to and all these
other things right where you consider
your child so just being open to
understanding as a storyteller that
there is an art side and there is a
business side I think that's really big
have you seen someone who has such
amazing talent as a writer but the notes
process ruin their career because they
were never able to be collaborative yes
but I think it probably happens more
often than we really know being a being
on a writing staff means that a you're
on the staff right now but B you have to
wait to see if the show is gonna get
picked back up if it does it doesn't
mean that you're automatically picked
back up and one of the ways that you
cannot get picked back up is you don't
take notes well right so some people are
often not getting picked back up on the
next season simply because they couldn't
take notes well and again especially if
you're on a staff you're here to write
someone else's baby so your opinion
matters but you writing what you're
being asked to write matters more right
so there are there are people who just
need it's like a learning curve for them
so I can't necessarily say that they
never worked again
maybe they learned from that and they
were able to work again there have also
been times when people in authority are
kind of mismanaging how they're doing
the writing by attaching themselves to
someone else's writing in that kind of
room process without realizing that the
writer is doing the writing just because
you're giving notes on the writing
doesn't make you a writer and so a lot
of the times depending upon where their
producers are show runners or directors
or whatever it is that they are they may
be getting confused in that part of the
process and now they attach themselves
to the writing and I know that there
have been people who have lost their
jobs because of things like that as well
simply because that's what their job is
this is what your job is just because
they work together doesn't mean that
they're now teams or coal writers or you
know coal whatever so that can happen as
well but that the game goes back to
people not really understanding how that
part of the industry works and some
people have to learn by trial and error
and it happens that way oh okay so I
yeah I didn't know that I never would
have thought of that so it's not just
the writer possibly getting hung up on
these notes it's also the note giver not
realizing their role their role as well
it's like you're the note Giver
that's a part of your responsibility
that doesn't make you a writer because
no givers may also give suggestions
right and so now they're thinking well I
gave XY and Z suggestions so now it's
you and I who have written this thing it
was like no writers are the ones who are
physically writing right if you are a
producer a showrunner or a director when
it comes to features right you may be
adding possibly but if you're not doing
and what the WGA has rules about if you
didn't do it particular percentage I'm
not gonna try to figure out remember
what the percentage was but if you did
do a percentage of the physical writing
and cannot put your name on as a writer
now in features things are gonna be a
little different anyway because the
writer has taken out so early in the
process right so there could be other
people who have come in and actually
done more writing and there's still a
percentage of writing that they have to
do before their name gets attached but
there's a difference in how their name
gets attached it might say
you see the word a in D then that means
this was an extra person who got
attached if you see the ampersand sign
that means they're a team that means
they wrote it together me and this
person wrote this script together if you
see the word and it means they wrote it
and then somebody else came in and put
their part and somebody else came in and
put their part so you might see one
person's name and then 50 other ends you
know because all of these other people
came in and they put in enough of a
percentage for them to be getting a
credit some people who are rewriters are
simply ghost writers and they never get
a credit but they might have come in and
done some writing but then once that
writing process is over and now that
script is in the hand of the director
he's gonna hear she is gonna go in and
change up all kinds of stuff doesn't
make him or her the writer so you're
rarely gonna see suddenly just because
now that the development is over in his
in production and the director is now
doing things with the script it's not
gonna necessarily now throw his or her
name on there because he or she is doing
what what he or she has to do in order
to make the production happen and they
may be making a lot of different
creative you know suggestions and
creative changes but it doesn't make
them the writer so again stay in your
life stay in your lane you got to know
what your lane is and stay in it
does a good story have to be believable
I think it depends on the tone right so
if it's a slapstick comedy nobody
expects you to believe it right if it's
a drama then there's got to be something
that's relatable enough for me to think
that this is possible but if it's
fantasy then the what relates to what I
know as a foundation is gonna be blown
into smithereens because the whole world
might be something new and something
different that I don't know anything
about so I don't necessarily think it
has to be believable but what I do think
is it has to be believable that your
protagonist can reach the goal that
you've set up for them to reach so even
if the world itself isn't believable
even if the goal itself isn't believable
but if I believe that this person I'm
investing in can actually get that thing
done then I'm probably gonna stay for
the journey was there a film that you've
seen where you just didn't feel that it
was believable even though the world
seemed like it was in reality first
whatever reason the story just wasn't
convincing enough I can't say off the
top of my tongue I know I've read some
scripts that way
definitely but I can't say off the top
of my head a screenplay that I felt
wasn't believable I think it happens in
TV a lot and that goes back to structure
I think a lot of the times TV shows may
get picked up and we kind of know kind
of where we wanted to go sometimes they
get picked up we have no idea where this
thing is going we're taking this thing
season by season and especially if you
get yourself into science-fiction places
sci-fi sins or sci-fi fans or the best
and the worst they're going to learn
your rules and know your world better
than you do and then now you're gonna be
in the writers room having to make up
new rules to get yourself out of holes
because you didn't realize these holes
were gonna happen and now your fans are
at home going nope there's no way that
would happen because this this this and
this they know all of the rules so they
then can catch you in it so now it's
unbelievable you know simply because
you're not working within the rules that
you set up so that happens in TV all the
time
I actually just I won't say the name of
this show by just watch the show the
other day was there serious finale and
they needed one of the protagonists
because an ensemble cast they need it
one of the protagonists to end up in a
particular place
and the way that they got her there
unbelievable upsettingly so it's like
she wouldn't do that she just wouldn't
do it
so I know that because as a writer you
needed her to get there you just said
well we needed or get need her to get
there this will be a cool way to make it
happen or a shocking way to make it
happen so let's do it this way but it's
like but that particular character would
not do that so it was unbelievable and
the audience for Sara oh yeah oh yeah
it's all over Twitter Facebook
everywhere people are like she wouldn't
do that
mm hm hmm interesting
so then is it also based on on sort of
like maybe the character isn't fleshed
out enough maybe some of the ones you
read use oh yeah definitely in when I'm
reading someone's like new work or
original work you know sometimes it's
just like well you don't really know who
this character is yet so you're having
them make make choices willy-nilly you
know and then one choice that they make
okay that may make some sense but then
this one doesn't and then but that
doesn't necessarily change anything we
have to think about the actions you're
taking towards your goal or like cause
and effect they're like trial and error
so you're learning along the way it's
like you know with anything you're doing
in life if I'm a baby and I'm learning
how to walk if I fall I learned
something from the fall so the next time
I'm not gonna do that same thing doesn't
mean I won't fall again I'm not gonna do
that same thing again right so the same
thing true the same thing is true with
your characters they should be learning
something along the way
so if they're not learning something
along the way
then it's like well it's probably cuz
you don't really know your character
very well but I think it's more so of
the thing of you know we want to get a
TV show made and we don't realize that
in five seasons we can kind of run out
of ideas or you can just kind of run out
of smoke or you might not even be
interested in these characters anymore
but you're still here and it's still
getting made they're still being ordered
and you got to put something on TV the
other thing like I said earlier is
writing staffs change and with writing
staffs changing skills may be changing
you may get a lot of new you know new
writers that come in in season three and
now they're learning on the job you know
what I mean you might get a new
showrunner
that comes in at the beginning someone
who's never run a show before right if
they've never want to show before you
might be learning on the job you might
get a new showrunner in the middle of
the series and now they're learning on
the job there's so many the executives
might change so the notes are now
changing and people don't realize how
much that can make an effect if you have
a very good executive who understands
your show and understands your
characters and the notes they give help
in the success of the show if you
suddenly get some executives who don't
know your show very well don't know your
characters very well but they're giving
notes because that's what they're
supposed to do now the notes aren't that
great and now they're pushing your show
into one direction or the other like you
never know it could be happening
anywhere but here I am as at home
watching it going man this series used
to be so good
like what happened it could be a number
of things that happened
how does the writer know what they were
good at oh good question
I think a lot of that's gonna come from
your own confidence a lot of that is
gonna come from
just like within just knowing like this
is a natural skill for me this is a
natural area for me but I do think it
takes some time to get there which is
why when writers work with me out
actually those kinds of questions like
are you writing what you'd like to write
or are you writing what you like to
watch are you writing characters that
you know very well or are you writing
characters that you observe which is
fine but make sure that if there are
people that you just observe that you
then try to get in there so you really
know why they do the things that they do
you know and I think a lot of the times
we write what we think is on trend we
write what we think people are going to
buy and by doing that you're not
necessarily finding your niche though
you might be finding I don't like this
but the question is are you then gonna
be honest with yourself and say I don't
like writing this so then you're stop
writing that and start writing what you
do like so I think it takes some work
but I also think it just takes some
honesty like within like just just like
it would for anyone who's working any
job there are people who are on their
job right now and they know I don't like
this or they know I have a different
skillset and I do like my job and I had
this skill set they can give me this
promotion but nobody else can see it
like people you know just kind of know
just like we said about that athlete
thing just kind of know that it's gonna
be football or basketball or golf or
whatever even though when you're a young
kid your parents might you know put you
in all five of them and eventually you
just narrow it down and say well this is
the one I like so the same thing is true
for writers I mean I think you have to
go with your first good write because
most people start writing because they
had an idea they usually aren't people
who just start writing because they're
in a writing class most people are I
have this idea so they start writing so
great
write it get it out see if your next
ideas in that same wheelhouse and then
what about your next one and if they're
all kind of in that same place then you
start to realize either this is what I
like or this is what I'm good at
but we also know just as again as people
a lot of us do a lot of us are great at
things that we don't like to do you know
you hear people say all the time like
this is what I'm great at but I want to
do that
like for example I'm a great teacher I
do not want to be a teacher
so the kind of teaching that I do is by
teaching adults in online screenwriting
courses or doing workshops so I'm still
a teacher as a script consultant I am a
teacher but I am NOT the what what
people consider a teacher I don't get up
every morning and have to be in a
classroom full of little people all day
I don't want to do it I've been fighting
it my whole life just the other day my
mother said to me well you know since
you work from home you should probably
go ahead and get your teaching
certification I don't want to be a
teacher you know but it's just a natural
you know a natural skill that I have to
be a teacher so the same thing is true
for a writer you just have to be honest
with yourself about this is my skill set
but is this what I like doing and figure
out if you can find like what that
middle ground is something that you're
skilled at and you actually like and
some people are group people and others
are excellent one-on-one I think yes so
and that's gonna matter because if
you're not a group person then you don't
want to write TV and so I have people
say all the time like I wouldn't be a TV
writer and it's like but you don't take
good notes you don't like to be around
people okay you know and you think that
this process is all about you you can't
possibly want to write TV TV most TV
shows it's changed a little bit because
now we have streamers now we have blah
blah blah so things happen all kinds of
different ways but most TV shows have a
writers room that you're gonna be stuck
in for weeks for you know 10 12 hours a
day sometimes with you and then
discussing discussing discussing
discussing you don't want to be around
people you might not want to write TV
the same is true for if you don't want
to move to Los Angeles you probably
don't want to write TV right because
most TV writers rooms are in Los Angeles
sure there are a couple literally a
couple in Atlanta maybe a couple in New
York but 90 something percent of the
writers rooms are here in Los Angeles
you don't have to live in office Angeles
to be a feature writer it's probably
best that you do at least in the
beginning of your career so you can meet
the people you need to meet because here
in LA in LA
because film is the industry you might
run into someone in the grocery store
you know I mean like these people are
everywhere and if you're gonna have a
meeting they're gonna call you in a lot
of times they're not gonna do their
first type meetings over the phone it's
just not gonna happen that way they want
you to come in they want to see you and
depending upon what you do for a living
you can't afford to fly and get a hotel
every single time you take a meeting
right so still being in LA it's probably
a good thing to do if you're a writer
because you want to be able to just be
in the mix meet the people get to know
the people and be able to see them face
to face but other than that after you've
established yourself as a feature writer
you can live wherever you want because
you can submit via email you know what I
mean you don't have to be here but for
TV writers most of the rooms are here so
that's something that people should take
into consideration when they're deciding
they want to be a writer you got to ask
yourself those questions too am i a team
player or do I want to do this thing
solo do I want to live in Los Angeles
how do I want to live in Connecticut
like where do you want to be
how many screenwriters have you come
across who only have one screenplay
completed most of them I would say the
majority of them only have one
screenplay completed and that's okay
especially if they're in the beginning
then they're still trying to figure out
what it is they want to do or if this is
really what they want to do or if again
I just have an idea and I want to get my
baby made then I don't expect them to
have more screenplays because it's not
about them becoming professional writers
it's about them getting their baby made
for those who I know want to be
professional writers then we start to
have those conversations about okay when
it's time for you to meet an agent or
manager or whoever whomever they're
gonna say what else do you have so you
got to have something else and again
thinking about branding yourself you
want to have something else within your
voice see we get it a little bit twisted
because we start to think well I want to
show them how diverse I am right so I'm
gonna have one of these and one of these
and one of these in one of these it
actually does the opposite for writers
if they don't already know you if you're
brand new it does the opposite they want
to be able to read three of your scripts
and understand you're a voice they want
and understand these are the characters
you write well
this is the world you know well right so
if you write big-city things then what's
in your writing sample should be big
city things if you write
all town things then all of your writing
samples should be small-town things and
it doesn't mean that you can't write
big-city things but you're just again
trying to say but this is my voice this
is what I write understand my brand so
it's not a negative thing if you only
have one screenplays just the question
is what do you want to do if you want to
be a professional writer then you got to
go write more because writers have to
write and if the people that you work
with as a script consultant or even just
email you to test the waters how many of
them have never let anyone else see that
one screenplay hmm I would say I think
it's a little hard now that it's we're
it's 2019 and there are AI script
coverage services all over the internet
so I don't meet very many people who
haven't let somebody else read it even
if they're not even if they aren't
professionals but I think I'm usually
the first like professional person that
they've had reading you know maybe mom
read it or sister read it or cousin
already you know but I think I'm usually
like one of the one of the first
professional people and I think that's
also because even though all of those
resources are out there a lot of people
never utilize the resources like they
haven't really googled people don't even
know and I'm not saying that they should
but they don't even know that a script
consultant exists so they're not
thinking let me go google script
consultant you know some of them are
thinking the only way I'm gonna learn
how to write a screenplay if I go to
film school they're not thinking there
are online classes there are one-day
workshops there are three day workshops
people aren't really thinking that so
they're not even looking for you know
they may the most they may do is like go
google some books and go to the library
and get the books or go buy the books or
amazon the books or whatever but for the
most part by the time they get to me I'm
like the first professional opinion
they're getting and they usually have
found me on social media by accident I'm
not even looking for me you know I think
that's how I found you
ya know that's the great thing about you
know 2020 is that people can just
randomly find you so I think they're
usually like oh my god you're the your
what I've been needing this whole time I
just didn't know that you existed you
know and that's the hard part about
being an entrepreneur is figuring out
you know how are you gonna market
yourself so people know that you exist
because it's like once people know me
they're like I need you and they usually
you usually utilize me and almost
all of them come back like all of my
clients are usually returned clients and
that's if they're writing quickly enough
because as we know somebody may write
something this year and they might not
write another thing for you know two
more years that happens with some people
but for those of those of my clients who
are actually trying to become
professional writers and they're writing
off and they always come back with
whatever their next project is and it
becomes like a team effort you know like
like I'm a part of the team if I'm gonna
write something Shannon's gonna read it
she's gonna give me some notes and she's
gonna be real with me I always tell
people if you don't want you know my
honest opinion again not my subjective
opinion cuz that's not what it's about
this is not about me saying this is good
or bad but if you don't want me to let
you know that some of the choices you're
making aren't being executed the way
that you think they're being executed
then I'm not the person for you you know
but if you want me to just give it to
you straight I'll give it to you
straight and at the end of the day you
can always not listen that's the best
part about it you don't have to take the
note because it's your work and you can
decide to do with it what you please do
you think most people are fine with that
in terms of they actually want you yeah
to give me I think I've only had I've
had maybe two or three people give push
back and I'm all wait I'm fine with it
because I'm not here to prove to you
that my feedback is correct this is
still art you can decide to do whatever
you know and so a lot of my feedback is
usually in questions because I don't
want to tell you what to think I want to
tell you what I think you're saying and
see if we're on the same page so I will
usually ask a whole lot of questions I
then sometimes get people who respond
back answering the questions it's like
that's not what I need you to do I'm
asking them because it's not clear on
your page so you need to go put that on
the page just like you can't stand
outside all the theaters and answer
everybody's questions I'm not asking you
to answer my questions here I'm saying
if I'm asking that means it's not there
if I'm asking whatever it is you're
trying to make happen isn't happening
sometimes that's okay sometimes that's
what you're doing on purpose fine I
don't need the answer you don't have to
prove anything to me I then will have
other people push back simply because
they got a different set of feedback
from somebody else
and that's fine I'll always say to them
great if you get
another set of feedback and that person
says what I said or that person said
with the other set the other person said
then now you know which direction to go
into because if you hear it more than
once then it's probably a problem right
so yeah I've had a couple of people push
back simply because they said well the
problem that you see is not a problem
and I say you know that's fine my only
feedback to that is if it wasn't a
problem we wouldn't be having this
conversation right like you sent it to
me because it's not working for you I've
given you the reasons why it's not
working
and you say well that's not why it's not
working well that's fine
you don't have to take the notes I wish
you best you know with your with your
project and hopefully it'll work out for
you I don't ever want someone's project
to not work just because I gave the note
and they didn't want to take it you know
what I mean like that's again what makes
it art so you don't have to take the
note but I think again going back to
well this is my baby or it's personal
I've been writing like I had one woman
respond I've been writing for this many
years and I've blah blah blah that's
great these are the problems that I see
hopefully it works out for you and
there's not very much you know much else
I can I can say to it but it's not it
doesn't become like a a war between
whose feedback is correct or isn't it
like I'm not gonna take it personally if
you don't take one note you know I'm
going to do my job to the best of my
ability as professional as I can
professionally as I can and you can take
it or you can leave it and that's okay
how should a writer start a screenplay
oh so there are several different ways
you can start a screenplay and a lot of
that goes back to whatever your idea is
there's probably thing that's going to
come to you first but you should
definitely then start trying to figure
out what all the rest of those elements
are so figuring out what the world is
knowing what the tone is a lot of people
may not think about tone but tone
matters
tone is that that that that that feeling
that makes this different from slapstick
comedy regular comedy romantic comedy
into kind of a comedic drama that is now
more regular drama family drama that
ends up now this gritty thriller thing
so it's kind of like the the nuance
between the genres right like what that
tone is and then knowing who your
characters are knowing who's gonna go on
this journey figuring out why we should
care about them figuring out how we're
gonna relate to them and relating to
them doesn't have to mean liking them we
just have to relate then knowing what
goal they're after because anything
that's on TV anything that's on anything
that's a feature is about a character
reaching a goal that's why we're here
we don't want to just see people go
through their day to day lives right we
want to see like their act or something
or something's after then you know
whatever it is but they have a goal
figuring out what the stakes are the
stakes are gonna be the why why am I
here why do I care what's what's going
on what are they gonna win what are they
gonna lose because if not then why do I
care if they reach the goal if they
don't if there's nothing at stake for
them then I am gonna be that much less
invested and people usually know what
the end is people usually kind of know
what the setup is and they kind of know
what the resolution is right
it's the second act where everyone kind
of falls apart and it's because we
really don't start acting our quick
asking ourselves how how are they gonna
get from A to B so I personally feel
like everyone should write an outline
they're gonna be writers who are reading
this like ha I've never written an
outline and I've done great that's great
you might have that special skills but
you know you also might be a person who
doesn't mind rewriting fifteen times
because no matter what you're going to
right right I think by writing the
outline and cut down the number of
rewrites because your first draft isn't
as terrible because you actually plotted
out what it is you're going to do so you
didn't just start at the blank page and
start writing and just like you know oh
well maybe they'll go this way maybe
they go that way because as soon as you
change one thing what does it do changes
everything else there's a domino effect
if you're doing that in outline form for
some people that's putting it on cards
some people that's putting it on a
whiteboard you know now you just erase
that one little part and write it write
it back or you move your your cards
around because you realize this scene
could probably be best there and it
heightens the stakes if we make this
thing happen here I do mine in a Word
document
and I put the actual scene heading on
top and then whatever is happening in
that scene so I can copy and paste that
whole little thing all over the place if
I want to so it's easier to kind of see
your story on paper and move it around
as much as you'd like before it gets
into script format it becomes a little
harder to do that so if you have an
outline and you really understand how
does this person get from A to C what
happens during B what do they physically
do so I'm always asking how and so
people will then answer that with with a
general answer and I'm gonna know I want
to know what the characters physically
doing like what am i watching them do
can you say well they're saving the
world how are they saving the world by
going to Starbucks are they saving the
world by having to go confront a bad guy
yes they have to confront the bad guy
how how did they find him where was he
was he just down the street you
know in another country he's in another
country how do they get there you know
do they take a bus do they take a train
do they have to fly do they swim you
know like all of these little details
about how we actually get from A to C
are the things that people don't think
about until they're on the page and then
there's in there stuck and they stop and
they're like I can't get past this part
and it's like yeah cuz you didn't think
about that part until you got here but
if you took some time to figure it out
before you get to the writing part now
the writing is fun cuz you got your note
so you're like okay this is what's
supposed to be happening right now
okay I get it and now it can happen a
little more clean than it would have if
you just went straight to the page and
so now maybe instead of doing five
rewrites you only have
due to so I teach a whole class called
no writer's block and that's what we do
we learn screenplay structure and by the
end of it you have an outline so that
you can go write whatever it is you want
to write also because you're learning
screenplay structure
now you can outline anything now you
know the structure of anything so it's
not just oh well I figured the outline
out for this idea now what it's like no
any idea can fall straight into that
same place so that you feel more
confident because that's the other
that's the where writer's block comes
from is that you just you're not
confident in what you're doing
but if you have a plan already right
it's like we were talking about earlier
if I already printed out my directions
or if I have my Google Maps on my phone
then I know where I'm going I say yes I
can't this is not a good example I was
gonna say I could say I want to drive to
Louisiana but if I don't look it up I
can't get there I happen to know where
Louisiana is from here so I could
probably get there but there are other
people who are like who would have no
idea that they can get on i-10 and get
all the way to Louisiana some people
might not know that but so they would
need to have those directions if you
don't have those directions now you're
veering you know left and now you've
taken a wrong turn and now you've done X
Y & Z and you've wasted however many
hours trying to get there when you could
add a straight shot it could just had
the directions so to me that's what an
outline is it's your Google Maps so that
you know where you're going so I think
beginning writers should definitely
start in that place well start by
learning structure right start by
understanding what elements it takes to
have a story and then outline what if
they say well I'm good at outlining the
my first few but now I just know I don't
need to know anything yeah I mean if
that's
everybody has to every writer has to
find their own process so outlines don't
work for everybody
Beach sheets don't work for everybody
treatments don't work for everybody you
have to figure out what works well for
you because I'm always thinking about
what's efficient and effective for me
most of the time because if I'm writing
a short I only need to know the big
beast right I don't have to outline the
whole thing you know if I'm writing a
feature I need to outline the whole
thing is I don't I don't want to get
stuck in the screenplay part
that's frustrating for me in my process
but if that's the part of the process
that you enjoy you can do it that way I
don't I don't tell people that it's like
a must but I do tell people especially
people who are learning or people who
aren't learning but they've been writing
for a while and they're trying to make
it more efficient you know so it's like
no I've never outlined before but I
always end up getting there it's like
yeah but do you get there in a year
because you might be able to get there
in three months you know maybe depending
upon wheels you have going on in your
life you know so definitely people don't
have to do it that way I think you have
to figure out what your process is and
and make sure that that process is
efficient for you again if you're trying
to be a professional writer because
you're trying that means you're trying
to write more than one thing a year
maybe sell more than one thing a year
you can't do that if everything that you
write takes you know 15 drafts in two
years to write so you want to look for
something that's more efficient and for
me writing the outline is just more
efficient one of the biggest mistakes a
screenwriter makes on page one ooh
mistakes on page one I think one of the
biggest mistakes is jumping into
something that's not going to teach us
anything so it doesn't matter to the
story but you think it's cool right so
understanding that those first few pages
are about the setup right so this is
this is me gathering information about
the character about the world about you
know I'm gonna start making assumptions
about what's gonna happen I'm not
looking for the inciting incident on
page one but I am looking for things
that are intentional and things that are
gonna help me understand at least who
this character is so that's why you'll
see a lot of action films open with an
action scene because you're teaching me
the skills that this protagonist has
you're teaching me that they know how to
fight they're usually the good guy
they're usually the winners or whatever
other information that you need me to
know and so now when the inciting
incident does happen and they say you're
gonna have to go off and save the world
I believe they can do it because you've
already shown me that they can so I
think it's easy on page one to just like
open with something that like you know
we call it the opening image right
on that opening image we're thinking
okay let's do something big let's do
something cool it's like but if that
doesn't have anything to do with your
story or if it doesn't have anything to
do with helping to build who your
character is that also should have
something to do with the story because
you can tell me all kinds of things
about your character but if that doesn't
matter to the story then I don't need to
know you might need to know as a writer
because it's gonna inform you as you're
right but do I need to know as an
audience so I think sometimes we get
stuck in a place where we're talking
about something that's cool or talking
about something that is exciting but it
really has nothing to do with anything
and now you've lost that executive who's
only giving you ten pages in the first
place because you've just spent the
first three pages with two people at a
cafe talking about something that's very
interesting but then we never see that
person they were just talking to ever
again and whatever it is they were
talking about has nothing to do with
what our protagonist is about to go and
you know journey go on on this journey
interesting why do you think people do
that why like who wouldn't this be
really cool well I'll open with this but
it like you said it doesn't even it
doesn't get back to I think it just goes
back to them not understanding
screenplay structure I think we just
watch movies and if you're only watching
for entertainment which is what most
people do that's why people like to go
to the movies with me or watch TV with
me because I'm not watching right but
you know most people who are watching
for entertainment are just taking in the
cool stuff you know and they go oh my
god wasn't it so cool when this open
like that it's like yes but what does
that have to do with your screenplay you
know like oh well you remember in this
movie when this happened so at this
point in 2020 we all grew up watching
movies right so that means there are
movie things that we get attached to
right so we're not necessarily thinking
about story we think about movie moments
you know like that's just a part of like
can you imagine the people were growing
up now like movie moments are gonna be
their thing so a lot of the times people
are writing screenplays because they're
writing with they what they've seen
already because they think that those
are the movie moments that make the film
instead of realizing that movie moment
mattered because of who those characters
were and what they were trying to get
done it means absolutely nothing in your
screenplay
it means budget in your dream like you
know we recently had a screenwriting
teacher tell us that 99% of screenplays
are rejected by the industry
after the first scene so is that true
your yes again if those first 10 or 15
pages I wouldn't necessarily say it's
the first scene it depends on who you're
sending it to because most places will
say at least to give it the 10 pages so
that we can say that we did our due
diligence right now you could have a
scene that last 10 pages you know you
could have only two or three scenes
within those 10 pages so that's yeah
totally it happens if you if you can't
capture me if I don't care about your
character within these first 10 or 15
pages if I don't again we haven't
reached that inciting incident so I
don't even know what this thing is about
anymore so now I'm just grasping for
straws I'm reading it you know there has
to be something that connects me so that
I can want to read the rest because
people these days we'll send you a
screenplay that's 200 pages long
where's time for that if you can't
connect me in those first 10 pages I am
not about to spend my next two hours
reading 200 pages it's like for what
when there's a whole stack of
screenplays here that might capture me
within the first 5 or 10 pages you know
why do I need to why do I need to spend
my time reading the 200 it's the same
thing when you're thinking about
television so a lot of the times people
will you know have a pilot and now
they're thinking of you know the next
couple of episodes and they're like oh
my god I'm really gonna get you at
Episode five I've got to wait five
episodes before I'm invested no one's
gonna do that if you can't catch me at
the pilot I don't mean as an audience I
mean like as the executives that's the
people you're pitching to the pilot is
what sells the series if you're telling
me that you're gonna go into this pitch
meeting you're gonna say to them wait
till we get to Episode five then that
sounds like episode five through the
pilot you know like you got to get me in
here and and because it's 2020 I could
be doing this I'm watching you know I
can be doing all kinds of things I can
have on what are these things people put
the like there's all kind of technology
and like I could be looking in a whole
nother dimension right now instead of
you know watching your television show
or your feature so you know if it's
gonna take five episodes before I get
there and I'm not saying it doesn't
happen cuz I will watch things and go it
didn't catch me until episode three
right but when you're in the room and
you're trying to sell it that pilot is
what's gonna sell it
not you saying to them because like it
there if you just pitched your pilot and
the people are just kind of like you're
like wait wait wait I didn't get to tell
them about it upper soul 5 that's why
they didn't buy it no no they didn't buy
it because the pilot wasn't interesting
or they weren't invested in what was
going on so it's the same thing is true
and once they have the script in their
hands because you can also come in and
pitch one thing and then you get the
script you're bored to tears or you're
like this is not what you pitched you
know you said it was one thing and now
I'm looking at the page and it's really
this other thing sometimes that might be
a good thing sometimes it may be a bad
thing but simply just because executives
are doing a million things some of them
are not just development executives but
they're also current programming current
programming executives which means
they're running shows that are on set
right now that are in production right
now that are in writers rooms right now
and they're taking pitch meetings and
reading scripts etc so they're reading
scripts from the shows that are already
being done they're reading scripts from
people who are coming to pitch they
don't have time to read all 200 pages of
your screenplay there and if they do
they're gonna scan it so they're still
not gonna even catch on catch on to like
all of the nuances and all of the
everything unless they are that invested
because you're you're you know grabbing
them that way so that's why those first
few pages have to catch them and it
doesn't mean I put an explosion so it
caught them you know because it's like
explosion for what hey you know what I
mean so it still has to make sense to
your story when you were teaching you
said at Florida State and you had the
students watch movies and then write
this was it almost like they were
writing coverage on it oh no so we would
be specifically talking about like
analyzing how costuming and makeup may
inform what you see how lighting may
inform was so we were talking about
cinematography we were talking about
directing we would talk about all of the
elements of the film industry that may
be informing what you're seeing on
screen but not the actual screenplay not
the screenplay literally just what
you're seeing mm-hmm so visual yes
because people will always say oh the
writer did a great job it's like well
you don't really know if that moment was
something a that the writer put in there
or if you were feeling that really
because what the light was doing with
music was doing you know what the
director may have act for what the
actors are giving you may have nothing
to do with the writing it's like
literally a separate thing so yeah we
didn't study the screenplays at all in
this particular class it was just
watching the films and analyzing all of
the different elements from production
that may be informing the film what film
that you used as one of the examples had
the most different responses to it hmmm
okay so I do not remember at all I know
we used to watch Annie Hall okay and we
watched do the right thing okay but
again going back to this whole writing
thing if Y if I sat down with the
students and had them explain to me what
they were seeing they could do it
putting it in the written form was an
entirely different thing so just you
know again going back to everybody might
have an idea but it doesn't make them a
writer like being able to take what you
have here and put it on the page is a
skill and I think we understand that
when we're school-aged because we're
doing it all the time then we become
adults when you say I'm a writer and
it's like yeah it's hard it's hard to
get stuff from here to there so a lot of
their grade was really based on how well
they could give me the information in
the written form which is why I was
would focus on thesis statements or even
bibliographies I had a student come to
me and say she had never heard of a
bibliography and we this is an
undergraduate course oh I told her this
cannot be telling the truth I would have
rather she just said I forgot to put it
in and then I would have let her go home
put it in and come back and get a grade
but because she said to me
no one's ever told me I had to cite
something before I just could not
believe it I was like that's just that
cannot be true so I gave her a 0 on the
M because I told them ahead of time if
you don't cite your sources you're going
to get a 0 if I hadn't told them that
and of course I wouldn't done it but
also I explained to them getting a 0
gives you an opportunity to redo it if I
give you the actual grade you might get
a 50 or a 49 or something because you
have did the assignment that's you're
not gonna be able to change the 0 you
can change that's fair
you know redo it and now you get a you
know a new grade on it so they would get
the zero and be hurt and hurt but they
didn't realize the zero is actually
helping you because if I actually just
great it for what it is you'd bet not
the grade that you want yeah I wish more
places gave zeroes that we could redo in
what other ways do screenplays make a
bad impression bad first impression yeah
bad first impression a lot of people
aren't that great at the English
language that's totally ok hire a
proofreader that's like that should be
writing one-on-one for anybody anywhere
a there's usually a spellcheck B there's
usually some kind of grammar check
outside of that there are people like
myself who get paid to proofread and
again just just like regular people
aren't that great with the English
language there are some executives who
language so they may read it and it may
mean nothing to them that there's a
grammatical error every other word that
there's something misspelled at every
other word that there are commas all
over the place and semicolons being
misused it might not mean anything to
them it'll be just your luck it ends up
on my desk because that to me makes you
a lazy writer it's not because I expect
you to be perfect at the English
language but I do expect you to care
enough that if your screenplay finally
got to my desk that you cared enough
about your story to not let proofreading
be the thing that makes me not read it
so I will just make that assumption that
you don't care so why should I so that's
like a very very big thing the same
thing is with formatting screenplay
formatting is different television
formatting is different
if you don't understand formatting find
someone who does and have them format
your script if you send your script to
me and it looks like a novel I'm not
gonna read it and I'm also going to
assume you didn't care enough about the
craft to figure out what this is
supposed to look like so if you don't
care I can't care right
it just it gives me a reason those will
be reasons for me to not even give it 15
pages as an exact I don't have to read
15 pages to know that you don't know
what you're doing and because this is an
industry that's so hard to get into and
we're usually only hire who they know in
the first place if you're telling them
right out the gate I have no idea what
I'm doing why should they have to
continue to read you know so that those
kind of lazy writer things are
definitely bad first impressions
how important is show don't tell did a
whole workshop one show don't tell I'm
sorry I did yeah okay it's on my site
for purchase actually great it's called
WTF does show don't tell me right
because a lot of people hear it all the
time but they really don't understand
what the note is so it's very important
most ly because this is a visual art
form so a lot of us learned how to write
by writing prose right most of us do not
learn screenplay writing or script
writing in any kind of format when we're
in elementary school or middle school
and not even high school for some people
some people go to college and it's still
more about theory it's not necessarily
about writing or like the class that
they took for me was about analyzing the
film's it wasn't about writing the
film's so there's a lot of people who
just don't get to learn that part so
they will end up using that prose kind
of language within their screenplay so
they will be telling me she feels angry
right now how do I know she feels angry
right now what am I seeing on the screen
what does her anger look like if that
same person walks into a room picks up
something and throws it now I know she's
angry you don't have to tell me she's
angry you just showed me that she was
angry
so she'll don't tell is very very
important when it comes to screenplays
and is another one of those things that
kind of shows you to be an amateur at
this to show that you're not very
professional at it or that you might be
just trying you're trying your hand at
it for the first time because you end up
with a whole lot of prose your end up
with a whole lot of telling well just
yesterday she had a fight with her
sister so today she's over it how do I
know what happened yesterday if you
didn't show me the scene when she had a
fight with her sister I don't know what
happened yesterday which means all I'm
saying is a person standing there you
know like if you can just imagine what
am I seeing as this screen as this scene
is going on so the scene says interior
apartment she had a terrible fight with
her sister yesterday what am I looking
at just a person standing there what's
the visual thing what's the active thing
so show don't tell extremely important
just on a side note I noticed on your
Instagram you had something that was
really funny about TV moms and how
there's there's a character trait to
them mm-hmm and I was just wondering if
you could just yeah so I can't remember
what I was watching it's a show that I
like a million little things I don't
know if anybody watches it's an ABC show
I like ABC programming and one of the
women's mothers was coming to visit and
she's like oh I'm gonna deal with my mom
and I just started to realize in a lot
of the content we take in people don't
like their mothers like the mother is
always this passive-aggressive very
critical character and I don't mean it
when the mother herself is the
protagonist like if the show was about
her then she's likeable because she has
to be or if it's a family show so like
you know it's an ensemble show and so
there's a mom and a dad and some
children the parents are likeable
because the show is about them all but
if those parents parents visit somebody
always doesn't like a mom you know or
even if it's a mother-in-law you know
what I mean there's always some tension
between the women you know and I'm just
like what is that about like why do we
write them that way and I'm not saying
that there aren't critical women just as
much as there are critical men in the
world but I'm like I don't know anyone
personally who has that kind of
relationship with their mother that if
their mother would show up the first
thing they would think is you know like
I just like sure if your mom starts
being mom you know then yeah you're like
okay mom I'm gonna do you know you get
you know you get into that kind of place
of like I know how to do it it's okay I
don't need you to tell me kind of thing
but the whole just like you know I can't
stand my mom I don't want her to come
around she's always so critical like she
doesn't even realize she's this critical
and white and I'm just like we always
end up writing our mother characters
that way and one of the reasons I think
we do that is because those are movie
moms and so when we write movies we
think oh she's supposed to be this way
this is how you know we write moms and
it's just like but it's your mom your
mom where's your friend's mom that way
like are there any moms the mom is
always like the antagonist you know well
I'm seeing a lot of commercials that are
like reinforcing you can still be a cool
mom and say I'm not a parent but like oh
I didn't know that was a thing yeah okay
so that's really important for moms to
be considered to be yes to be considered
cool and I think it's because they don't
want to be considered critical or you
know it passive-aggressive or whatever
these things are so it's like you being
cool is now a thing and I'm like yeah
and I don't think we realize how much
our industry plays a part in what we're
pushing as what a mom is you know what I
mean
I think in the Gilmore Girls was it was
a peri gilpin it's character she was a
cool mom yeah I think so I don't I don't
remember I it was so long ago but I
think I think their whole thing was she
had her daughter at a young age so she
was a cool mom but that's what made her
not cool is that the daughter was more
of the mom then the mom okay so it was
like sure she's not this overly critical
blah blah blah she's the irresponsible
one though right
you know between them you know gotcha
okay but in the nanny that could
probably be mm-hmm a friend wrestlers
mom mm-hmm great character mm-hmm but I
think there was more of that dynamic
yeah like think about Everybody Loves
Raymond mm-hmm and the parents cut the
street
you know it's like yeah I mean I think
if she's funny and everybody likes her
and blah blah blah but all of the adult
children are like Oh mom you know oh
sure sure even if you go to some of the
eighties comedies like the the John
Hughes and stuff you could see yeah
there would be that the the parents were
right yeah like pretty in pink or
whether you know just the parents were
people that were not accessible not if
we don't talk to them
and I think that's another reason why a
lot of teen shows don't even have
parents like present and I'm always like
where are their parents like I'm always
thinking that when I'm watching like
teen shows like we're the parents why
why don't we why don't we know what our
kids are out you know doing you know
because I think again it goes from that
like well they're unaccessible kind of
people so we just kind of keep them in
the backdrop and every now and again
like when I watch 13 reasons why I'm
always wondering like where the parents
like where are they and sure they show
up every now and again but it still
always after the fact you know what I
mean
and I'm just always thinking like when
all these decisions are being made and
these kids are in your house and all
these like where is everyone
so yeah it's kind of a thing and then
what about the role of the dad are they
that are they sort of the the placate er
are they they like the the neutral one
mhm
they're either very neutral or very cool
or you know well mom's not gonna let me
do it but I know dad will like you know
they like dad's the the go-to guy and
mom is always the like the
disciplinarian you know I mean there's
because then you have your daddy's
little girls or then you have the dad
and son are like really cool cuz they
you know relate and and you know go to
events together and blah blah blah and
the moms always just like so prickly no
one wants to hang out with her when
she's at home or even like when I'm
watching the Americans I haven't
finished it I don't even know what
season I'm on but they're getting a
divorce and the children automatically
blamed them up automatically and it was
just like and not to say that either one
of them were was at fault because the
Americans is a whole thing that they're
spies in the first place you know and so
they were made to get married so there
was no love right so they have been
together for so long now their kids or
teenagers and they're really realizing
like well why are we you know really
doing this why are we staying together
like we've never really loved each other
so they're deciding it's apart and the
teenage daughter automatically was like
it's your fault mom mmm not dad's fault
and it's like where does this come from
yeah what are some of your favorite
characters of all time and what makes
them so great hmm good question favorite
characters you know what I don't know
why I can watch Twilight every time it
comes on isn't that crazy
I am into Twilight I actually read the
books in while reading the books I
understood a little bit more why these
characters fall so deeply in love with
each other but it also by
I got to like book I can't remember how
many books there were I know they made
five movies so maybe that meant there
were four books by the time I got to
book three it also became a little too
much for me
like their love affair their teenage
love affair became a lot and I so I
couldn't get into it when I saw the
first movie it was laughable I literally
because I didn't know anything about the
series I hadn't read the book yet I saw
the first movie and I wanted my money
back because the production value was so
I was I was laughing I was like why are
we here why are we watching this this is
terrible and now I can watch all of it
because it is something about how much
they care about each other that just
reels you in I just I don't even know
how to explain it for Harry Potter I'm
just into the fantastical world I think
I watch it and I just think of JK
Rowling and go like how did you like
what is going on in your brain so I'm
into her world I guess more so than I am
the characters simply because when you
when you make a new world you have to
make the new rules you have to come up
with the names you have to do you know
you have to kind of design what this
place is gonna look like and it's just
so fantastical and so anytime it's any
time of a movie is like within a series
I always almost like the first one first
because it's the introduction into the
world so I can re-watch like the first
Harry Potter all the time because we're
we're in his fish out of water you know
point of view being introduced into this
world and it's always so fascinating to
me I mean oh look Friday Night Lights
I don't even know why those characters
stick with me because you know I was a
cheerleader sure but I wasn't very into
football if I wasn't a cheerleader I
probably would not have been at the
football games so again it was probably
the world that that got me in and I
guess that's that's the thing for me I
think if I'm interested in the world
then I can probably ride along with
what's going on I don't know why in the
moment I can't think of any particular
characters that have made a difference
for me I mean maybe some actors like
back in the 90s I loved a good Eddie
Murphy film you know I always knew I was
gonna get something great out of him so
I loved coming to America and that's
another fish I just a fish outta water
story but he's
into our water so it's not a new world
for us but we're seeing it you know from
his point of view yeah I don't know I
can't think of any
did you like dolomite I did like
dolomite and I literally only watched it
because it was Eddie Murphy coming to do
something again even though I did not
watch when he was on Saturday like
Saturday Night Live cuz I'm just not
into sketch copy I don't know why I'm
just not into it so um but yes I did
watch dolomite it was really good I
enjoyed it mm-hmm yeah now I'm gonna see
what this coming to America 2 is gonna
be about because it's not something I
think it's necessary there's all these
remakes you know that are happening and
I think the majority of them are
unnecessary it doesn't mean that it
won't end up being a good film or a good
TV show or whatever that's being remade
but that just says to me Hollywood is
like basically saying no to all of the
new ideas and they're just trying to
redo what they think people already want
or what has already proven to work and
we know that there's so many writers who
are out here trying to get their stuff
done so it's a little you know
frustrating in that way of like another
remake so we'll see we're coming to
America two days I feel that way about
songs but then I realized that there
were songs when I was younger that I
didn't realize they were remakes yeah I
thought they were incredible yes so I
wonder if it's just the evolution of you
know each generation wants its own
everything and then I go put that that
one was so great this write and sound
the same say I'm always like leave it
alone just later what steps can a writer
take to make a three-dimensional
character oh good I think you got to
start thinking about who they are
physically emotionally socially you got
to figure out what their vulnerabilities
are what their flaws are what they're
good at what they're not good at what
their insecurities are because we're all
motivated by that we're motivated by our
insecurities people do things because
they're trying to feed whatever hole is
on the inside of them so I do a whole
trauma and stress lesson during my no
writers black course because every one
of us has a trauma even if your trauma
may seem small to me and my trauma may
seem small to you we each have a trauma
and on some level that trauma created
our insecurities and our insecurities is
what feeds us that's our motivation so I
always give the exam
of the characters in The Wizard of Oz
because the lion is cowardly
he says if I can get Dorothy to Oz then
I am NOT a coward because what I have to
go through makes me brave it's not
because he really cares about Dorothy he
wants to take her office hey you know
what I mean it's because he's a coward
and so at some point he has to decide
okay in order to be brave and get rid of
the Cowardly stuff and I got to go
through something that gets me there so
that's the thing that motivates you know
him to actually do the external thing so
that internal thing is really the
motivator for the external thing and so
I feel like that's true for people and
if we realize that about people then we
realize that about characters and then
that's how they become that's how they
get dipped and they become more
believable well if we go back to Harry
Potter what what are some of his wounds
that then show up and we so his biggest
wound is identity right he's he's not
being raised by his parents so that's in
and of itself going to be a trauma
whether you knew it him he knew he
always knew that these weren't his
parents so that's something that has
always been inside him all of the time
some people don't find that information
out until later and then the trauma
starts right but for him he always knew
these are not my people on top of that
the people who were raising him were
mistreating him and abusing him so
that's a second trauma and then on top
of that he's a weirdo who can hear
snakes talking and sometimes make things
disappear and so all he's thinking is
I'm this other that no one loves so I
think that's one of the reasons he has a
hero complex that he has to save other
people and always be looking that's why
his friends are so important to him
and why he has to save people because of
that whole of identity of who am i who
loves me who do I love back and where do
I belong how do we get a viewer to care
about a character I think it goes back
to that same stuff like if I can
understand why you do what you're doing
then that's gonna be far more relatable
because we're all almost all of us are
are working from that same kind of place
right so for example
if I am always seeing a person being
lazy it's easy for me to just assume or
they're lazy but if I understand that
really they're overwhelmed and they want
to be a they don't know where to start
and they want to be able to ask
questions but don't know what question
to ask so they're really frozen in that
spot and not being lazy that I can
understand now I've been in a place
where it's like yo I need some
information but I don't even know where
to begin
for whatever reason I've been equipped
to then figure it out maybe this person
hasn't so maybe I now have a different
perspective of who that person is by
understanding that they're just frozen
in time because they don't know which
way to go because they don't have those
kind of skills to do so now they're not
lazy they're overwhelmed I think all of
us can relate to overwhelm people more
so than we can relate to a lazy person
it seems like there's so many films with
great production value especially now
but sometimes there's a disconnect with
the character so this goes back to how
come we're not always caring about these
characters but the world looks great
there's just something missing about our
emotional connections yeah if that if
that kind of thing happens and I would
definitely say it's probably something
that happened in the writing it's
probably something that's not on the on
the page to attach that emotional
journey to the physical journey and so
we're missing out on it sometimes that
happens purposefully because they were
more excited about the world and they
were more excited about the production
value and that's what they wanted to
give you and they figured that part
would be the thing that makes you
excited about it and sometimes that
happens you know sometimes people
depending upon what they're making who's
making it why they're making it who has
the money to throw at it it may just be
I want to tell this big you know fantasy
story and that's the part that matters
so that's what you get it just really
depends again going back to those
executives who have now decided to
purchase the script and take it into
development if they care about the
characters then it's gonna get pulled
out if they don't it might not you know
if the brand of the place is you just
want to make big you know slasher films
that don't
now you don't care about the people you
people just died then they're not gonna
spend time on trying to make you like
them they're gonna give you just one or
two things there so that you know that
this is the good guy and you know the
slasher is the bad guy and then they're
just gonna make a movie so it just
really depends on what what they're
trying to get across you know when
they're when they're doing it but
definitely if you're not able to
emotionally connect then something
happened in the writing the question is
why was it allowed
well can you teach us about raising the
stakes mm um I think the biggest thing
to think about when raising the stakes
is how is it then going to affect the
rest of the story so sometimes the
stakes will be raised just because the
stakes need to be raised right so there
just be this extra thing that's just
thrown in there so people can go oh
right but again if it's not attached to
anything if it's not gonna make our
character have to make a real decision
that's going to affect them and then
affect the rest of the story sometimes
when those stakes are raised that's when
that redirection happens in the film
where we thought that this was the goal
they were going after after within the
stakes get raised and now they are going
in a different direction
so again everything is cause and effect
so even the thing that causes the stakes
to raise has to be obvious for your
audience to understand what's happening
right and then the fact that the stakes
are being raised like for example let's
just make something simple let's say
it's a singing contest and the the prize
is $1,000 and I'm a person who is trying
to go to college and I really need this
$1,000 because it's gonna pay for my
dorm right so the stakes are if I don't
get the thousand dollars I don't have a
dorm right you can raise the stakes by
saying my mother is also sick at home
and I just went to the doctor's office
and they say they can't start her her
treatment unless I can give a deposit of
$1,000 so sure you cared when she wasn't
gonna have a dorm room but she knows she
already has a house and she lives with
her mother so she doesn't have a dorm
room right but now - no but her mother
needs treatment and that extra thing
that she might find out along the way
now
the dorm room doesn't matter at all the
stakes are raised we want her to win
this singing competition if there were
no dorm room and there were no mother we
still might want her to win the singing
competition but if she didn't okay
I mean maybe was a nice movie you know
like yay she sang a song and she got her
$1,000 whoo we all at home know $1,000
not a lot of money right but
simply by giving they're giving it a
stake in the first place well I really
want to be able to move in the dorm but
my mother can't afford the dorm so if I
get this $1,000 I can move into the dorm
and start my independent life now we're
like okay we could get with that that's
relatable we understand that cool but
then along the way mom gets sick she
goes to the doctor that bill was a
thousand dollars let's say it's 750
let's say it's a thousand let's say it's
1,100 you know I probably not gonna be
right on the nose you know what every
day's but whatever it is we now know
that if she wins that money she can help
her mom so the stakes have been raised
because it helps us to get that much
more invested so that she went so that
should we vote for her
the stakes are about us being able to
root for that character so if that's
gonna help us root for the character
board and let's go there but if it
really doesn't change it like let's say
it's a thousand dollars for the dorm and
then suddenly now you could win eleven
hundred dollars it's like who cares if
there's another 100 dollars that you can
get like how does that really raised the
stakes or change the story like sure it
changes the money and if we think the
money are the stakes that now we're
thinking I've made a difference it's now
$1100 I really got to get it now
no not very much but just by figuring
out something that's going to affect
that character and and using that to
raise the stakes is going to be that
going to make that much more of a
difference
how do you write a great scene ooh I
think you should look at your scenes
like you look at the whole screenplay
and figure out the cause and effect of
what does this scene
cause to happen and how is it how is it
the effect of what happened before it
understanding that in every scene there
is a goal just like there is in the
entire screenplay the only reason we're
seeing this scene is because it's
getting you closer to or further away
from your goal and so if you look at it
like there's a goal that has to be
reached so that you can get to the next
thing that gets to the next thing that
gets to the next thing then you end up
not having scenes that are back to just
regular activity instead of intentional
action or even considering from an
actor's point of view when they're gonna
play out that scene one of them is
winning right somebody's gonna win in
this thing in this scene you know it's
kind of like it's a fact it's a fight
it's a ding-ding-ding in this corner and
in this corner these characters are
gonna come and whatever it is that
they're saying to each other someone's
gonna win emotionally someone's gonna
lose someone might physically win
someone might lose but what that means
is now that emotional journey that I was
on has been changed again it's the cause
and effect so there might be a physical
cause and in fact there might be an
emotional cause and effect or it might
be both but definitely looking at the
little looking at the scenes like
they're little movies right like what is
it setting up for me what's the goal of
this scene and then how does it resolve
to get me to the next thing so if we
were to take the hypothetical female
character who was entering a singing
contest now she's found out that her
mother needs this deposit start
treatment so that great scene is going
to be maybe her getting that news and
then she knows that that contest is
coming up and all the things that she's
got to do - I don't know just because
the stakes are risen it's not just like
oh yeah I need it for my dorm yeah where
I want to buy an ice bag or something
yeah so now her action because of that
scene because of that new information
her intentional action is going to
change so maybe before then she wasn't
practicing very much cuz she's got a
natural voice you know so she wasn't
practicing very much she wasn't finding
any new songs she's like oh yeah I'll
just uncle up there
you know whatever cuz every time I sing
this song it's great but now this thing
has been a humbling moment for her right
so now we're gonna see her going to her
lessons we're gonna see her trying to
find the best song like she's going to
be putting a different kind of action
into it because now the stakes are risen
now there's something something more at
stake right so now she's gonna put a
different kind of action into it so that
thing is gonna cause her to change
exactly
mm-hmm what are your thoughts on an
artist quitting their day job to pursue
the quote dreams in Hollywood be
prepared have a savings account do not
quit until you have a savings account
however what a lot of people don't know
about Los Angeles is it's not the kind
of place unless you're in an industry
that can transfer your job like
literally you know some people can well
I'm working in the in Indianapolis
office and I'll just ask them to
transfer me to the Los Angeles office
that's not in every industry but in some
industries that exist you can do that do
that instead of quitting your job right
get transferred to that office or if you
have a skill like let's say you're a
paramedic then apply for some paramedic
jobs out here so that you can have
something to do while you're writing on
the side I would not like because
writers until you actually have your
screenplays ready and you're going into
meetings and taking meetings with people
there's nothing specific that you're
doing in the middle of the day so you
can write at night like you're not like
an actor where it's like I have to have
a night job because auditions are during
the day right so no matter where you are
in your acting life if you come out to
LA you probably have to get a night kind
of job or a part-time kind of job
because you need to be available during
the day period writers you don't
necessarily need that right off the bat
especially if you've never written
anything and you don't have enough
samples or anything yet then you won't
need that so it's okay for you to have a
job you just now have to be disciplined
enough to write at night or write on the
weekends even if you just give yourself
an hour a day however long it's going to
take if you do decide to quit and you
say well I'll just get a job out in
lausanne
Julis please note what a lot of people
don't know about la is they're not gonna
hire you unless you're here if you're
getting hired into this industry so if
you're saying well I'm gonna be an
assistant or I'm gonna be a PA or I'm
gonna I don't know do whatever it is you
plan to do in this industry if they call
you for an interview nine times out of
ten it's cuz they want you they might
say see you tomorrow
and you're in Indianapolis so it's one
of those things where it's like it's a
big risk but you got to come out here
first then you'll be able to get the
jobs a little bit more easily not to
saying that it is easy but more easily
than it would be when you're away
because again you're meeting people
you're around people they can introduce
you to people and when they say hey can
you come in for this interview or hey
can you start tomorrow you can say yes
because you're physically here I have
seen and it has happened to me where I
have been passed over because they're
like can you start tomorrow and I'm like
oh well I'm moving you know next month
and that's because people think like
other industries well once I get the job
they'll give me a start date it'll
probably be two weeks from now or a
month from now
and it's like no that's not how this
industry works like they're on set right
now they need someone to come in right
now so it's not one of those things
where you can kind of be set up already
before you get here you got to get here
and then apply so that's why having a
savings account is a really big deal
it's also very expensive to live out
here so unless you have a roommate or
somebody like that be prepared very very
expensive so if you know that this is
somewhere you want to come at least give
yourself a year I have a long you need
to get your savings account up before
you get out of here you started your
courses your online courses partly out
of necessity - right do you created your
own job for yours yeah I did actually I
did so I used to be a creative executive
a decade ago and I left that job to be a
performing artist so I could travel the
world so I got to go to 19 countries 48
states had a great time but within that
decade the industry continues on so even
though I was still working with writers
to help on their screenplays because
they were contacting me I wasn't
contacting them but people knew I did
that so they went hey
rethus hey can you see this so
eventually I made it into my side hustle
you know when you're performing artists
your contract the contracts and when
you're out of contract you still have to
be making money some kind of way so I
kind of used to do that on the side so
when I moved back here I figured it'd
probably take me a little while before I
can get back into the industry and
people know me and I can get where I
need to go so in the meantime in between
time I got to be able to be making some
money so why not take this skill that I
have and people have been asking me to
do this and turn it into my day job and
so here I am a year and a couple of
months later and it's just still what I
do full-time everyday that's great thank
you
and and do you think back to what if
someone had offered you some easy job
for the money and then maybe you would
have taken it for the paycheck and then
you wouldn't have developed this and
your website you know I don't think I
would have done that this time around um
when I came to LA this time I've lived
in LA three times when I came to LA this
time I knew exactly what it is that I
wanted and I knew what the path was to
get there so I knew that I may have to
take a job I didn't like in order to get
into the right room but if I thought
that job wasn't going to get me into the
right room I would not take me would not
have taken it however actually be having
the experience that I have is it's what
keeps me out of the rooms
I'm usually seen as overqualified so as
much as I send out my resume I don't
have very many people who actually call
me in for interviews and for the jobs
that I should be able to apply to those
are the who do you know kind of jobs and
so because I was gone for a decade then
I don't have access to those jobs either
so I'm kind of stuck in the middle I'm
overqualified for these jobs and I don't
have access to these jobs okay fine so
I'll start my own job and Here I am yeah
that's something that a lot of people
probably would would think oh that's a
good problem to have but it's actually
holds a lot of people back overqualified
overeducated
I've never had that problem but but I
know that other people have it you can
really hinder what you do yeah
definitely so I could have let that get
me down and you know move back to Texas
etc but because I at this age know what
my strengths and weaknesses are and I
know what I know and I know
I don't know this is what I do well so
I'm gonna do this for myself until at
some point someone realizes oh you have
the actual I mean the exact skill that
we're looking for in this particular
position and if that's something I'm
interested in doing I'll do it and if
it's not I won't I'll continue to do
what I what I'm doing now I definitely
during that time of being a performing
artist and having to take side jobs and
random jobs I've done enough things that
I don't want to do I've had my share of
it I'm done with that so now it's about
being on being on track you know well
that was my last question and just the
worst the worst job and I'm sure you
won't mention the name but then what
happened and how did you leave it um
oh no it was just I actually ended up
writing a screenplay about it that
placed in a couple of competitions last
year uh but I was a sample lady like in
the grocery store oh yeah I did that too
yeah and people always assumed that
those people worked there and it's like
no I didn't work he I didn't work there
was hired by a company right and do it
yeah and it was really frustrating
because people didn't want my samples
they just kept asking me questions about
stuff in the store and I didn't know
anything about the stuff in the store so
my screenplay that I wrote ended up
being about but what if this was the
only thing you had like for me sure I
could have again been a teacher right
there's other so I actually became a
substitute teacher so I still ended up
doing what I had been fighting all that
time but I was like as a substitute
teacher you get to at least choose your
own schedule right you can decide to go
in and you can decide not to so I did
that but I was like what if there was a
person in all they had was this sample
lady job like that's it right now what's
their story so I ended up writing a
screenplay called truffle sauce because
that's what I was selling did you find
that everybody told you like their life
story like their secret oh yeah they
wanted to come and talk to me and do
everything but taste the truffle sauce
thank you that's what yeah they would
say I don't want this wait do you work
at Costco too on the weekend no I don't
but then I would end up hearing very
personal stories and they just because
they knew I was safe I was in danger
they probably would never see again and
it was actually really interesting to
interact with people it was the most
frustrating job for me as I out there
do this again even though I probably did
it like one or two more times think I
dated like three times and I was like
okay I'm done
guess I'll just substitute each the
Health Department threw away my samples
I don't know it was a must she must have
been like new or looking for a higher
position yeah he came in looks at other
stuff and then she saw my table and just
said throw him in the trash
she's a bit been sitting out too long
yeah do me a favor
no yeah possibly
[Laughter]